merci merci madame la présidente
il y as pour moi deux raisons de fond
qui explique la méfiance justifiée
d'ailleurs des opinions publiques à
l'égard de cet accord commercial
la première d'entre elles c'est pas
seulement la transparence c'est qu'au
fond les peuples les opinions publiques
n'ont pas été associés aux débats ne
savent pas ce qui se passe et moi je
regrette que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement est donné mandat à la
commission de négocier sans
préalablement baru des débats dans
chacun de leurs états membres et je
souhaite que les parlements nationaux et
au final leur accord ou non à donner à
cet accord ça c'est très important
le deuxième point c'est que les opinions
publiques ont le sentiment à juste titre
que nous ne sommes pas à armes égales
avec les états unis que nous ne faisons
pas jeu égal avec les états unis que les
américains des formes mieux les intérêts
des américains que les européens ne
défendent les intérêts des européens
et si on prend simplement la question
des marchés publics nous nous disons que
nous voulons qu les marchés publics
america soit ouvert les marchés publics
américains ils sont ouverts et réservée
aux petites et moyennes entreprises
américaines les américains ont raison de
le faire les européens devraient le
faire et donc je vous demande de nous
demande de regarder en face ses deux
raisons de fond qui font effectivement
une grande partie des doutes et des
inquiétudes légitimement exprimées je
vous remercie